author of The New York Times bestseller
on freedom of the press as you know I
call him the great one he hosts life
liberty and Levin the number one show
8:00 p.m. Sunday night right here on the
Fox News Channel also syndicated radio
host and this Sunday he has a very
special guest me for the full hour great
one there's a lot of seriousness here
because we really get to the heart of
this this is your wheelhouse
this is about the Constitution our
framers and founders never imagined this
well let's take a look at this first
well let's look at the Committee
Chairman and the speaker yeah Pelosi
Schiff and Nadler what do they have in
common a lot of things they talked about
the rule of law they come from sanctuary
cities that nullify federal law and they
support that they obstruct ice and law
enforcement they reject our immigration
laws and now they're talking about the
rule of law they don't believe in the
rule of law the Constitution's the law
of the land not any of these potentates
that run these committees and not Nancy
Pelosi it's the president's duty to
uphold the Constitution not a rogue
house with the Democrats are in control
literally every president who crosses
the House of Representatives in the
future under the standardless procedures
they have been placed with abuse of
power and obstruction of Congress is
subject to potential impeachment if they
don't bow to the will of the majority in
the House of Representatives first of
all obstruction of Congress they say
right has the Senate done anything yet
so house an obstruction of Congress it's
obstruction of a rogue faction of
radical Democrats in the House of
Representatives once they won the
majority they immediately ran for
impeachment the President of the United
States has no obligation to them abuse
of power they talk about when the
president the United States like every
past president even since George
Washington has fought to protect the
office of the presidency against a
Congress that is out of control
that demands his innermost information
from his innermost witnesses individuals
who who report to him and he goes to
court and they say that's a
struction let me tell you something
every past president who would be
subject to impeachment under the current
articles being debated in the House of
Representatives John Adams would be
impeached he shut down newspapers he
imprisoned reporters Abraham Lincoln
would be impeached he shut down 300
newspapers he imprisoned reporters
Thomas Jefferson would be impeached the
Louisiana Purchase without budget
approval from the Congress Woodrow
Wilson would be impeached
Jiri segregated the Civil Service and he
put political opponents and reporters in
prison he would be impeached
they're great FDR would be impeached
internment of japanese-americans Italian
Americans German Americans took their
property took their homes used the
Internal Revenue Service against the
Philadelphia Inquirer owner against the
Gannett owner use the IRS against his
political opponents like Huey Long FDR
would be impeached 25 times John Kennedy
would be impeached use the IRS and the
FBI against his political opponents
leaked information against them Lyndon
Johnson would be impeached use the IRS
the FBI and the CIA to tap into his
political opponents into the civil
rights leaders and by the way became a
multi-millionaire while he was a senator
we'd have a lot of impeachment going on
under these bogus rules that this rogue
House Democrat leadership has put in
place let's look at the history the
Democrat Party it's an ugly history with
some gaps of goodness the party of
slavery the party of segregation the
party of Jim Crow and when the Democrat
Party does what it does like that it
needs to be slammed down and it needs to
be slammed down now the next Democrat
president of the United States must be
impeach not to get even not because
we're at their low level because the
Republicans can't live under one
Constitution when the Democrats live
under another Constitution and it's the
only way
we're gonna stop them one party can't be
allowed to abuse the Constitution yet
wave it around while the other party
sits there and takes it the Democrat
Party must be slammed down that next
Democrat president if they vote for
impeachment against President Donald
Trump must be impeached and we have the
blueprint
it's the Pelosi project she even said
today we've been at this for 22 months
four four four two years what do you
mean we're being fast here we have the
plan endless unconstitutional subpoenas
no resort to judicial review no due
process accusers are protected from
scrutiny phone calls of foreign leaders
must be released the president's closest
advisors must testify tax returns
business records bank records business
associates all subject to congressional
access and demand the appointment of a
special counsel
that's the Pelosi project it must become
the Republican project when there is a
Democrat president one other thing
look at this damn thing this is five
hundred pay this is the Muller report it
took them five hundred pages to say the
president United States is an innocent
man who didn't correct commit any crimes
five hundred pages two and a half years
forty million dollars that's that now we
have another one that's five hundred
pages I look at this look at this what
is this this is an Inspector General
report that says what that says the
Obama administration listen mr. holder
the Obama administration spied on the
Trump campaign tampered with evidence
repeatedly lied to a federal court the
FISA Court to get bogus warrants four
times renewed use the dossier paid for
by the Clinton campaign in the DNC that
they knew was bogus and that they used
all of this lies and crimes to get this
a Special Counsel report that says
you're President of the United States is
an innocent man Donald Trump is
upholding the Constitution Donald Trump
is the victim it is the members of the
House of Representatives that
crash they're the ones who need to be
impeached that's it great one thank you
life liberty and Levin I will be marks
guests Sunday night eight o'clock right
here on Fox hope you'll watch